now we're getting some information more
information about the Prime Minister
here let's talk to our political
correspondent Joe pike who is it
Westminster so some new information I
understand about the Prime Minister and
his condition
that's right Mok Dan extremely relates
his statement in the last few minutes
saying Boris Johnson is a walking or
doing short walks at least this is the
statement the Prime Minister has been
able to do short walks between periods
of rest as part of the care he is
receiving to aid his recovery he has
spoken to his doctors and thanks the
whole clinical team for the incredible
care he has received his thoughts are
with those affected by this terrible
disease now I understand that update is
from some thomas' it's not something
that Downing Street have written
themselves and therefore it's still
unclear whether the Prime Minister has
had direct contact with officials at a
number-10 no word yet on his discharge
from Thomas's and no word of course on
the length of his expected recovery so
we don't know quite when he'll be
returning back to work but certainly a
positive sign that he is able to do
short walks between periods of rest a
feeling that's obviously very good news
the feeling is that the recuperation
period might be quite some time as you
say yes some medical experts have
suggested for every day in intensive
care a patient should have a week's rest
of the cooporation a Boris Johnson was
in intensive care at st. Thomas's for
three days that would obviously make
three weeks and what is clear is that
the government's direction on its
response to Kova at 19 is already set
pretty clearly almost certainly the
government will extend that three-week
lockdown period late next week maybe for
another three weeks so actually there
isn't a great need for Boris Johnson to
be at the heart of government making
decisions every day the key decision
mark is when to release that lockdown
whether when to lift that lock and that
may not be made for another month so he
may have a long recuperation perhaps in
check as some have suggested that the
official country residence is the place
for him to recover not in a flat above
Downing Street close the nerve center of
the government's response but no word
yet quite on how long that recuperation
will be